socialism used to be a dirty word in the
US but now for many young Americans
strapped with debt disenchanted with
mainstream politics and uncertain about
their economic future socialist ideas
might just be a breath of fresh air so
what is this new political movement and
have we seen it before so Zack you join
the DSA when I joined it the morning
after the presidential election 2016
when Trump was elected so you were
scared socialist why do you think so
many young people like yourself are
joining DSA we've seen what the system
does to people and how much people are
struggling and things aren't getting
better for like the 99% like we're
seeing rich people get richer and richer
Lucey Macias is the co-chair of the
Chicago chapter of Democratic socialists
of America a national organization that
works on grassroots campaigns stages
actions like confronting the homeland
security secretary during her Mexican
dinner and help select like-minded
candidates I think what's great about
the idea of electro work is like we can
have a foot in the electoral door but we
also have a foot and like other work DSA
is now approaching fifty thousand
members nationwide with a hundred and
sixty-seven branches a number that
surged since Bernie Sanders presidential
run and unlike in 2016 Democratic
Socialist candidates are winning from
national victories like Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes and Rasheeda Talib two
races at all levels of government it's
enough to cause panic both in the GOP
and within the Democratic Party I'm here
in the Logan Square area of Chicago and
I'm about to meet up with our councilman
who happens to be a Democratic Socialist
and guess what
he's only 28
did you just knock on doors where like
hey I'm a socialist well you know I
think that um sometimes people get
confused by a label and so when I
knocked on doors I said I was going to
stand up to the big corporations that
were too powerful in City Hall I was
going to make sure that our public
dollars benefit our public schools
benefited our communities and invested
in after-school programs job programs
mental health services and it wasn't
until later after I was elected that I
came out and said I'm a Democratic
Socialist if you're a Democratic
Socialist why not run on the Socialist
Party ticket people that want to tax the
rich they want to protect immigrants
they want to stand up for women's rights
for workers rights they're already
voting in large numbers for the
Democratic Party line so let's actually
give them what they really want and
let's give them Democratic socialists on
that party line that are actually going
to deliver the policies that the
Democratic Party should be standing for
damn this guy has got it together and he
doesn't mince words when calling out
moderate Dems I think here in the
context of Chicago I learned the
Democratic Party is very much tied to
the establishment and the moneyed
interests do you think that the moderate
Democrats and the establishment
Democrats are afraid of you guys
absolutely we can see you know when they
begin to fight you that's when you
really know that they feel threatened by
you
all these inspiring young socialist
candidates running for office and
it feels unprecedented what is it
why socialism in America and throughout
the industrialized world first took root
in trade unions and in a movement to
protect and advance the rights of
workers Chicago was once the center of
the Industrial Revolution and along with
explosive growth and profit came a whole
lot of exploitation people are working
16 hours a day living in terrible
conditions this is just a fact and a
movement began called the eight hour day
movement eight hours for work eight
hours for sleep eight hours for what you
will meet Larry Spivak the premier labor
history tour guide of Chicago you want
labor history you go to Larry that
monument there is what the exact site of
where the Haymarket rally of May 4th
1886 took place which is sort of some
could argue one of the most important
and influential historical events of the
last 150 years in the world the
Haymarket affair happened when a labor
protest in support of the eight-hour
work day turned violent ultimately
ending in the death sentence of four
activists it was a tragedy in so many
ways for those who were killed and for
its setback the working-class movement
for a while it was really the first Red
Scare red scare tactics meant portraying
socialist ideas as somehow foreign and
unamerican back in the day calling for
free health care would get you accused
of being an agent of the Soviet Union
today you'll be accused of wanting to
turn this country into Venezuela one
third of Chicago is German speaking at
that time today it's one third
spanish-speaking but the Germans were
despised basically you could take today
and go back to 1886 and instead of and
just substitute Latin American or
Mexican for German and you get the
xenophobia and the America first and the
native-born
hatred towards these German immigrants
but how foreign of a concept is
socialism this is John Nichols who wrote
the book the S word a short history of
an American tradition a history that's
actually quite long America has always
had a socialist or Social Democratic
presence going back to the founding of
the country in the very first years of
the Republic Tom Paine wrote it as
pamphlet agrarian justice that was in
1797 and so you know even before the
word socialism was used
you had people advocating for solutions
to problems that involved a
redistribution of the wealth would have
been these economic conditions and the
conditions of the United States that
have led to these socialist movement in
the 1890s start of the 1900s first off
you saw a great economic downturn in
1893 but then you also saw the Gilded
Age this incredible inequality in that
period in the 1930s you saw a similar
thing with a Great Depression of course
but also you know immense wealth
surrounded by great poverty and
Roosevelt really started to talk about
that others did as well and so again and
again throughout history what we have
seen our moments where economic
turbulence and technological change that
combination has caused people to pause
and say hey who's got an idea here who's
got a solution for the circumstance
you're in because the wealth is not
distributed appropriately the power is
not distributed appropriately we are
oppressing some people while empowering
others are we in right now when it comes
to capitalism and exploitation
entire push and pull of history we are
currently experiencing the equivalent of
free industrial revolutions at the same
time and there's a real sense of lack of
control that the great mass of people
aren't making the decisions about our
technological changes all this change is
happening but we don't necessarily get a
signal that things are getting a lot
better and in a moment like that it is
incredibly necessary to have new ideas
time into 2018 I'm back at another DSA
meetings they seem to do a lot of this
you know things are happening in this
world where people are hurting people
are not able to have a place to live
people aren't able to access healthcare
people are literally dying because their
GoFundMe to get insulin fell like $50
short like it really is sometimes life
or death for people so like this is why
we believe so much in what we do I do
think that democratic socialism has
historically been about the meeting in a
sweaty hall late at night it's about
going to the mom was that the the
drive-through at the Wendy's or the
Burger King and treat her as a human
being and respecting the struggles that
she is facing economically and trying to
come up with answers for her and I do
see in the contemporary movement a lot
of them I see a lot of young activists
who are going out and making very
practical connections with people if
they continue to do it my sense is that
this is a movement that will stick
[Applause]
[Music]
you